oh there we got this uncommon for people
to see a toilet seat just like fully
presenting itself are we all cool with
that done cool with that no welcome to I
have long hair now and I'm still
figuring out how to style it on my own
hi my name is herself jet no no no your
life is different now natural lighting
in a hotel on an overcast day Brooklyn
it is truly the best lighting why do I
even invest in a ring leg I'm currently
in a hotel in Brooklyn is Hannah Hart's
third book release day Mary and I are
going to be guests in the show that she
is doing here in Brooklyn to launch book
this is all the same sentence just
rearranging the word it's been a second
since I'm doing a video in a hotel room
so let's take advantage of that it's
been a hot second since I've done a
favorites video and I actually have some
things to talk to you about that I'm
very excited about I'm already tired
favorites videos get harder as you get
older I'm acquiring a bunch of new
products because I've been trying to use
what I have I've been just the opposite
of consumerism I guess I've been
enjoying ISM recently I have a couple
things that I truly love and I probably
may be or not mention these in favorites
videos in the past which if anything
shouldn't be a downer they should be
actually just more encouragement that
these are in fact favorites let's jump
into it my sense of humor is one of my
favorite things about me also I'm
drinking a monster energy drink so I'm
just going full my if the brawny man had
a daughter who is into gaming you know
what let's start here because this is
one of my favorite yes say yes say yes
yes see this is a flannel that I bought
it Zara I think it was 40 bucks 50 bucks
baby it's real fun because it doubles as
a coat look at this I can wear it
buttoned up as a shirt but then I can
also wear it as a coat and I just feel
like it gives me that extra layer of
protection also the extra layer of like
hey I'm down to like refurbish an
Airstream and also down to like do some
pickleback shots it gives me a fake
layer of coolness I also feel like it
had a wild night with a lumberjack and
this is like my walk of shame I chopped
down
some hard trees in the woods last night
next is NYX micro brow pencil yeah it's
completely empty just finish this today
which hardly happens in my world
finishing something other than a
lumberjack monster energy drink has
really turned me into a 13 year old
pervert it's the super chief brow pencil
that I bought at like a CVS or rite-aid
I love it it's got a little spooley on
one end you get what we used to have the
Browse stuff on this end texture of this
is somewhere in between a pencil and a
gel and I like that a lot and it helps
the brows out a lot so I like this I
forget how favorites videos work next
yes yeah yeah this is a tinted
moisturizer elta MD skincare UV daily I
love tinted moisturizers because I'm bad
at skincare and I like full coverage
makeup so if I wear a tinted moisturizer
that gets my moisturizer in and also
gives me like a primer foundation base
to put foundation on top of it this
really actually feels moisturizing I got
this on Amazon and it was one of like
the highest reviewed ones so I also
listened to other people's
recommendations
hence pay it forward
SPF 40 in it I got to protect the
moneymaker I hate myself for that
I don't know how much it was but it
wasn't incredibly like Sephora levels of
expensive I don't think don't hold me to
it here's the fun part of this video
where there's so much information an
opinion and then a complete vague broad
spectrum of maybe it cost this I don't
know I think it works I don't know next
say yes yes yes I literally just went
downstairs to CVS and bought because I
just got hair extensions in and I forget
about taking good care of my hair it's a
10 miracle leave-in for blonde WOM I
I say that word like I was swallowing a
blimp in my mouth I love it's a ten
products because I feel like I forget to
travel with shampoo and conditioner
because we all do and so I end up using
Hotel shampoo and conditioner and it's
not the best but I feel like this
reverses all of that just the great
equalizer I didn't do the best job with
my hair today but it's like any of their
leave-in Spray stuff I think it's
wonderful because it takes that little
like a I'm wiry dog hair feeling on your
hair from using like Hotel shampoo and
conditioner and then I just like smooths
it out into like a little velvet poodle
that's a great drag name by the way
please welcome to the stage about the
coudl it's a little bit pricey but this
kind of stuff I think is worth it all so
it's 4 fluid ounces which i think is
what I'm allowed to travel with we're
gonna find out tomorrow when I fly back
to LA yes I think I can't actually see
it this is the thing I think it's fair
to say that I have an affinity for
blankets I like clothes that feel like
blankets
I like having hair to my head that feels
like a little blanket and I actually
like blankets I think I sort of Buffy
because if you haven't you should I
didn't scream at pop-up for me that
recommended Buffy blankets technically
they're comforters they're not blankets
the company's name is Buffy and they
make comforters you guys get it I just
wanted to clarify I feel like the you
know vampires liner explain can actually
do slay your vampire tendency it's like
if you're prone to insomnia which I am
like it puts you to bed I think I also
just came up with their next marketing
campaign I bought a puffy blanket I
didn't love it - no and and then they
reached out and they were like hey can
we sponsor a video and I was like yeah
you can and also can I get the other
comforter that you advertise the one
that says like you don't have to sweat
in your sleep anymore because I'm a
sleep sweater I think it's because I
just keep piling things onto my body I
also think it's because I don't shower
that like earlier that my body is trying
to regulate some sort of like organic
shower for myself anyway
I sweat in my sleep they have natural
benefits of Buffy made from ultra smooth
eucalyptus fibers what do we deserve
that I guess so it's way softer than
cotton
and it's cool to the touch so it
regulates your body temperature when you
sleep if you're asleep sweater like me
and all their products because they have
comforters will be able to have sheets
and pillowcases which they just sent me
and they're being amazing are
hypoallergenic cruelty free you just
feel good all around and if you're
curious they offer free trials free
shipping and free return pretty free
books me I already had their cloud
comforter which is like the one that
basically makes your bed feel like
you're sleeping in a cloud and then I
just got the sweaty Betty comforter
that's not the real name what is the
real name of it
it's the breeze it's called the breeze
I've had the breeze for like two weeks
now I'm deeply deeply obsessed with it
[Music]
got you I got you on camera I tried to
pack it with me no offence hotels you're
fun and you're weird but this comforter
doesn't even come close a while I'm in
New York I miss my dog I miss my
boyfriend
I miss my breeze I know you guys can get
$20 off this buffy bedding by using the
link in the description box below use
promo code grace get $20 off your buffy
purchase as much as I feel like you know
a 13 year old boy
I am maturing because this is something
that really matters to me comforters
this is a makeup setting spray from
Bella Jade botanicals I saw this in a
BuzzFeed post recently her products you
might not know about that are like under
ten dollars that people swear by I did
the thing where I got excited I just
clicked some buttons and then this
showed up at my door I hardly ever wear
powder like setting powder on my face so
I go with setting sprays more often to
keep my makeup lasting longer and this
[ __ ] has been amazing it has kept
everything you're looking kind of dewy
and fresh but also just like locked and
loaded feels super lightweight it
doesn't feel drying and it also feels
like it does a great job you know what
it's really fun when something does a
great job that you hoped would do a
great job I think that's it okay that's
it for this video those my current
favorite things that I genuinely truly
love I hope you go check out the
comforters if we want to I cannot wait
to fly back tomorrow to literally just
jump face-first into that beautiful
sweet less sweaty thing there's a joke
to be inserted there about like my
boyfriend's body but if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up don't forget
to subscribe to this YouTube channel
I've been making videos
you know when weekend Oh make sure that
you listen to this make it weird the
podcast I do with mamrie Hart comes out
every Wednesday too deep is out every
Monday and other than that this is fun
guys
old school hotel bus I don't know
I got you on camera